after six long years of fighting the
allies finally defeated the german war
machine in 1945. in july of that year
the leaders of the allies roosevelt
churchill and stalin met at the potsdam
conference to decide what would become
of germany and how to divide the spoils
of war now publicly the allied leaders
were friendly and respectful but
privately it was a different story when
the cameras were off there was anger
mistrust and hours of arguing stalin
felt that churchill was weak and
deceitful and roosevelt threw a fit when
he heard stalin's demands for war
reparations that even though the soviet
union and the united states were allies
they weren't friends the potsdam
conference marked the end of the last
war
but it was the beginning of a new one
[Music]
on august 4th 1945 just a few days after
potsdam united states ambassador william
avril harriman received a gift from a
group of soviet children who belong to
the vladimir lenin all union pioneer
organization the vlada what they were
like uh russian boy scouts and girl
scouts but uh
more patriotic
[Music]
whoa yeah something tells me these kids
don't sell cookies nope intense the kids
presented the ambassador with an
impressive gift to commemorate the
friendship of the u.s and the soviet
union a hand-carved wooden replica of
the great seal of the united states the
ambassador was so pleased with the
carving that he hung it in his office at
the official ambassador residence in
moscow the spazzo house what harriman
didn't realize is that the wooden
carving was more than just a decoration
now hanging on the wall just behind the
ambassador's desk was a state-of-the-art
high-frequency listening device that was
completely undetectable ambassador
harriman held private meetings with
military diplomatic and intelligence
officials there he had top secret
conversations with generals the
secretary of state and the president and
the russians they could hear every word
oh boy how long before they found this
bug seven years for crying out loud yep
the intelligence community called the
device the thing you gotta be
kidding and the thing was on the office
wall of five different ambassadors over
seven years how did they finally find it
well by accident actually and that's
what makes the thing so interesting and
so effective this was an electronic
listening device that didn't require
electricity
diplomats serving at the american
embassy in moscow were very concerned
about soviet spying all staff from the
cooks to the cleaners were background
checked they were constantly sweeping
for bugs and even people visiting the
embassy were given cards on arrival that
warned them that they should assume all
rooms and even outdoor spaces were being
monitored even with all these security
measures in place the soviet secret
police were somehow able to listen to
the american ambassador's private
conversations for years completely
undetected the thing was created by leon
theremin a russian inventor most famous
for developing one of the world's first
electronic musical instruments which he
called the theremin name checks out it's
all about branding i don't think i've
ever heard of a theremin oh you have
[Music]
no okay i know that one night bring back
david tennant sorry sorry i get
emotional about dr who i understand in
the 1920s thereiman was touring the
world showing off his invention even
performed with the new york philharmonic
and at carnegie hall now eventually he
set up a lab in new york and developed
one of the first metal detectors for
alcatraz prison he also created an
electronic burglar alarm and was the
first person to demonstrate interlaced
video now this was advanced stuff for
the 1920s thereiman was churning out
inventions working with thomas edison
and really making a name for himself but
in 1938
he suddenly disappeared
when leon theremin suddenly and
mysteriously disappeared from new york
in 1938 it was reported that he was
executed but eyewitnesses said that they
saw him talking to several tough-talking
russians who um
encouraged him to return to the soviet
union did he go back well the other
option was a firing squad he went back
he did in russia thereiman was put in a
siberian gulag and given a choice he
could work a gold mine breaking big
rocks into smaller ones or he could work
at a sharashka which is a secret lab for
detained scientists and engineers he
chose the lab he did at the secret lab
thereman was tasked with developing new
surveillance technology to bug the us
embassy and the spazzo house his first
success was an infrared microphone
called a boron eavesdropping device
which inspired the modern laser
microphone and it worked by emitting a
low-power ir beam to detect vibrations
on glass windows now the boron system
worked well but it required good line of
sight which the russians didn't have at
the spazzo house in moscow they needed
to get something inside
so thurman invented the thing the first
resonant cavity microphone the thing was
light hollow and it was made of wood so
it would vibrate when sound passed into
it now this is a lot like how a guitar
body generates sound when strings
vibrate but the thing was shaped so that
sound wouldn't amplify outwards like a
guitar but instead sound waves were
focused on an interior membrane that
acted as a microphone and the microphone
was attached to a small antenna which
could broadcast radio waves but radios
need power to broadcast and that's why
the thing is so unique it didn't have
its own power source and wasn't
connected with wires instead it was
activated externally the nsa calls this
technique illuminating a device when the
russians knew an important meeting was
happening at the embassy they would park
an unmarked van somewhere close by and
then using a strong radio transmitter
agents could activate the things antenna
remotely and listen to conversations at
will once the thing was no longer
illuminated it was completely inert now
this was genius cutting edge and highly
effective that's why it operated for
years undetected
until
in 1951 a full six years after the thing
was installed in the american embassy in
moscow a british army radio operator was
randomly scanning frequencies coming
from the moscow airport then suddenly he
heard what sounded like an american
conversation now as he tuned the signal
he realized he recognized one of the
voices as the british air attache now
completely by accident he had tuned into
the kgb frequency now he alerted the
embassy who conducted a full bug sweep
but they found nothing then about a year
later another operative was scanning
soviet military radio traffic when he
picked up a conversation in english that
seemed to be coming from the spazzo
house the new ambassador george kennan
called in a special anti-espionage unit
to perform a sweep but this time they
focused on radio traffic so kenneth went
to his office and pretended to dictate
an important message to his secretary
the american radio tech switched on
their equipment and picked up the signal
almost immediately and it was coming
from something very close by it's coming
from inside the house exactly a few
minutes later they triangulated the
signal and found the source hanging
right there on the wall
it was the thing so you remember my name
now do you during those seven years the
thing gathered top secret information
from some very high level guests
including general eisenhower white house
staff and a dozen congressmen a member
of the soviet team that monitored the
espazo house later said the thing
allowed the kgb to get specific and very
important information which gave us
certain advantages in the prediction and
performances of world politics in the
difficult period of the cold war that
night a radio technician slept with the
thing under his pillow just in case the
kgb tried to retrieve it the next day it
was sent to washington to be studied
what did the russians say about this oh
nothing the americans and the british
didn't say a word for years no what did
they do with it they reverse engineered
it to use on the soviets yeah i saw that
coming
whatever information the thing provided
to the russians it eventually came back
to bite them in may 1960 an american u2
spy plane was shot down over soviet
airspace a few weeks later at a u.n
national security council meeting the
soviets accused the united states of
spying and drafted a resolution that
would have the un officially condemn the
u.s call the violation of soviet
airspace an aggressive act and force
american flights to stop so for three
days the soviets presented arguments
attacking the u.s the united states was
accused of war mongering being an
untrustworthy nation and threatening
world peace the soviets argued that
countries who spied on each other should
be condemned and espionage and
surveillance are considered acts of
aggression right right right the
americans quietly took the punishment
then on day four when it was finally
time for the u.s to present its rebuttal
it simply brought out the thing
ambassador large counters repeated
denials of soviet spy activities with a
concrete and dramatic example he tells
how the soviet planted a listening
device in america's moscow embassy
concealed inside a wooden carving of the
great seal presented as a gift by the
russians the thing was top secret for
almost 10 years but now the entire world
was shown spying goes both ways
[Music]
and here is the
here is the clandestine listening device
uh you can see the antenna in the area
and it was right
the un voted against the soviet
resolution 7-2 and now thanks to a
wooden carving delivered by children as
a gift of peace and friendship the cold
war was in full swing and nuclear war
seemed more likely than ever
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the white files if you had
fun or learned anything do me a favor
and like comment subscribe share all
that stuff really helps with the
algorithm and until next time be safe be
kind
and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
[Applause]
you